okay here to show us how we can turn
can't soup
that's right can't stupid do a delicious
and nutritious meal please welcome Abby
sharp hello it's a staple everyone's got
this in their pantry it's not very
satisfying though because I find I need
to eat a whole can and I'm starving
afterward me too right so we're gonna
amp this up with lots of fiber and
protein and good stuff so we got
mushroom Canada mushroom soup delicious
not even like it's like a cuff you know
no that's exactly the most appetizing
all on its own but we're gonna make it
way better okay so you know it's
something that everyone has on hand I
know my grandma threw that on every
casserole and gave dinner is it on the
three the three bean casserole that I
was brought up yeah yeah yeah exactly
exactly holiday staple we probably have
it for that so I just popped that into
the pan here with the water I've got
half a cup of skim milk this is the kind
of traditional way to make your gear
canned mushroom soup we've got broccoli
here so I've just chopped this up really
nice and fine but use whatever kind of
veggies you have on hand if you've got
beans if you've got peas really anything
will work I've got some quinoa that I've
already cooked up because I always keep
like a whole batch of quinoa that I like
to just throw into soups and salads
really that's already cooked up but you
didn't do anything with the broccoli no
because it's just gonna barely cook
through so fast this is like the easiest
weeknight meal cannellini beans so I've
got some these ones are no salt added
because we want to stretch the sodium
per serving a lot of these soups as you
know are really high in sodium so if we
can kind of make a meal that is and
really stretch the sodium per serving
we're laughs I do still rinse those out
when you get fine oh yes rinse them
drain them of course yeah on the no sell
added ones cuz I don't like the they get
a little starchy yes and then this is
just garlic powder but really any
seasonings you like there you go lay
with it and there you have it right
there yes we're gonna just garnish this
up it's a little
open-faced grilled cheese some
whole-grain Bay got little old cheddar
cheese cuz I like the really old I like
that fight bite with a little little
goes a long way okay what are you doing
in my tomato soup that I love on the
door so much I know it's my favorite too
it's great with the grilled cheese right
so we're gonna make a like a five minute
chili it could not be simpler oh this
one's this one's hot and ready hop it
what's ready for it so the soup goes in
half of cans worth of the water and then
you know we're making a vegetarian chili
with some black beans again I use the no
salt added throw those in drain rinse
them you could do a meat-based chili if
you want to as well but this is great
because sometimes when I'm watching a
football game I want it an instant chili
instant and and usually they take you
know all day to simmer so yeah I've
drained the the moisture out of the
canned tomatoes here that way you don't
need to wait for a dry you cannot and
then we never bet you you've got so I've
got some beautiful bell pepper I've got
some zucchini lots of fiber right here
some corn cuz I love that sweetness in
my in my chili okay and then whatever
spices you like what are you adding I
would show you do the chili powder
powder garlic powder uh-huh and a little
bit of cumin which is like my favorite
thing in the world cumin okay smells so
good and then again let that simmer to
the veggies just soften up we're gonna
just garnish that not a thing of beauty
premiere what's up are you on trow she
loves okay then you lost me on that one
good yeah but still good so really good
and now butternut squash soup it's so
comforting right well stand back
bubbling guys bubbling right okay this
has got crazy a little crazy so we're
just gonna go from afar here so like
ramen a little bit put the camera Kaelyn
there you go then write that down
alright that's it's good now so fine it
hop right we chopped that killed yeah
yeah cooks nice and quick I've got some
whole green rice here with mix with a
little bit of wild rays that I love
yeah and then I've got some turkey
sausage I've just taken out casing
sauteed it up but again use whatever
leftovers if you've got rotisserie
chicken you got leftover turkey from the
holiday parties throw that in there for
your fiber and your protein we're
getting the knots from the audience
crank oh haha I like that yeah yeah this
is my garnish cuz I like everything to
have a little bit of garnish and so I've
taken some leftover pumpernickel bread
cut it into little cubes sauteed it up
with some sage mmm it smells like the
holidays sage is that characteristic
Paula Davis and that's what we're going
for us okay just do that again you take
your your pumpernickel bread
okay and then you cut it into low Q yes
and use if you've got like kind of semi
snails like you might as well use that
up pop it in the little fry pan with a
touch of olive oil and some sage that
you just minced up nice and fine Oh easy
crew tongs with leftovers right so all
of these soups you know you've starting
with a pantry staple and you're
basically throwing in things that you've
got in your fridge and pantry anyway
right right that's right and you're not
really adding any more salt or which I
love exactly we're stretching the salt
and adding fiber and protein
okay mushroom tomato and squash there
you go insta meals thank you to add a
shark
all right everyone all of these recipes
are on Maryland ROTC ed so after you
probably know this but at the beginning
of the show a big day today did you
enjoy your wonderful gift
tomorrow when Marilyn Amanda's back with
a beautiful holiday room makeover